okay people joining this live stream uh
we are talking about bio sequence
functionality which it seems will make
it as experimental functionality in
version 12.2 which is good all right
let's take a look here uh where should
we start should we start looking at the
new system functions and things that
sounds
great
okay let's get a let's get a basic sense
of this first and then then we'll go
into details okay because it's been a
while since I looked at this so we got
bio sequence which is the basic
representation of a thing like
presumably Pro protein DNA
RNA that's right anything else we also
have support for circular
DNA
okay I don't on this
one and by the way the general rule is
you don't get to use more than one line
in these descriptions uh sorry noted yes
uh so that one concerns whether or not
uh matches must be strict uh
that that must cover all of the letters
that could be or whether any of the
letters that might match a given pattern
are sufficient uh for
example
uh if the if someone has given the
sequence s which is the degenerate term
for between C and G uh does g match uh
understand I understand enough said yep
I understand so an N for example would
match everything in biosequence match q
but it would not in strict biosequence
match
pattern right would not if you wrapped
strict bio sequence mat bio strict
biosequence pattern around an N right n
is usually it doesn't know what it is
right that's right so right right so if
you wrap strict around it that wouldn't
match a T for example right that's a
sequence with n would it match a pattern
containing a t if this is
true what is this a wrapper or is this
an option this is an option to uh bio
sequence match que I don't think it's a
well- named
option I think it should be it should be
match
um
strict strictly match bio sequences or
something because this looks like a
wrapper okay which is what I thought it
was see what I'm saying I see yeah I can
change that
yeah I'm not completely sure what it
should be changed to but but that looks
like a wrapper okay I'm just going to do
a quick look down here and
then
how that's like converting from a DNA to
um
uh
um uh to to protein and things like that
right right this is that's the super
function that uh can convert kind of
anything that can be converted between
each other it builds a a graph and makes
all the necessary
conversions okay that's nice
um and why is there a seate complement
function rather than just being convert
to other
strand in yeah there was no yeah there
hasn't been a notion of other strand
although there could
be I mean convert I mean these are
probably convenient yes compliment and
reverse compliment but I think convert
could also support you know
complimentary whatever it is right yes
yeah
okay why is convert a DNA sequence to
corresponding RNA why isn't that just
part of biosequence
convert why there's why there's
transcribe and translate uh no yeah no
no I asked why isn't this part of
biosequence convert transcribe is just
converting a DNA sequence to RNA so just
say biosequence convert blah blah blah
comma
RNA yeah uh uh
that that that could work uh
yes okay could Mel or somebody else
respond about this I mean you had
earlier said it would be nice to have
the most common terms represented as a
function that's probably correct that's
probably
correct okay I'm just trying to
understand the logic here
okay but probably these could all also
be supported in biosequence convert
in general they are yeah well are they
so bios sequence translate takes a lot
of options or a lot of conversion tables
and things and so uh it isn't clear how
to fit it into the general bio sequence
convert yet
okay
okay come on do not have to put a
capital letter there
okay it's not the final version yet okay
fine number of potential
sequences wow I's a lot of detailed
stuff about
conversions do
resolve by the way somebody's breathing
is should be adjusted or that phone
should be
adusted
um
what is all this stuff
here yes so if someone has a sequence
that contains degenerate terms if they
apply right things like by what you mean
n and things like that right n and
things like that if they apply if they
ask for all of the potential
transcriptions or or or or translations
or conversions or so forth that can be a
very large number understand I
understand I understand so what this
is
that's interesting I mean that's a a
string replace list type
thing which we don't have for Strings
that is saying you know in a string
replace an N with
either you know
acgt and generate all strings do we
extremely placess does an operation a
little bit like that but it isn't
exactly that
right
so we should understand what the
general case of this
is I I'd like to know what the cor how
it corresponds to St Place
list
okay okay so these sequence comparisons
would work directly on bio sequences
right that's
right
that's not great okay so there's a
linking to entities right that that's
right yeah there will be this is in
development as Michael has said yes okay
all right great all right let's take a
look over
here
it might
make if maybe if we start with the
things that are slated for
12.2 I understand I'm trying to
understand so that I know when I'm
looking at the design of the 12.2 stuff
I'm trying to understand what it is
you're designing for in the future I
see this is not my first design
review
okay so if I take
this why is it taking so long is it
loading a bunch of stuff y um okay so my
so I see you had already done the plus
there okay fine how do I find out how
long that sequence
is so there's uh both if you expand it
there should be sequence lengths in
there I don't want that I there's also a
sequence length subv value
okay okay what what's the list of sub
values let's see there's type sequence
string sequence length and chemical
list
I don't see it here yeah these the yeah
this is all the uh the review notebook
has has is the latest I've been updating
these but
okay all right okay so you're
saying if I want to reverse this I don't
get to do that there's no bio sequence
reverse
that's true there's not there's not a
built-in reverse that's right we had
long discussions about
this is it not useful it's a complicated
like do we really want more less to
repeat every string function I mebe
cannot overload them this is too
strange it's a good question we had a
general operate on function but it
seemed a little bit
complicated but so the minimum way I can
do this is to
say sequence
string string
Reverse by the way string reverse you
could
overload reverse you couldn't but string
reverse you
could I'm sure some people
complain I mean we could
but I mean we could have the same
solution what we do for molecule where
the BIOS sequence modify where you could
then do whatever you wanted to do 50
different
possibilities doesn't sound totally
silly
although modifi suggest it's in
place well not really I was going to say
it doesn't really make sense in our
world
yeah
okay can I say protein instead of
peptide or do I have to say
peptide uh you have to say peptide
although we could give alternate
standard names and it would
work
um that is just a protein right that's
right so we should allow protein as
well somebody might want to adjust the
microphone
again yeah that's nice it's very nice so
if I say um C vertical bar G will it do
the same
thing uh that just came back in
Michael's review of this so we're going
to make uh we're going to include that
and also make have it round trip so you
can get that form out as a sub value as
well how with a different sub value like
resolved string
sequence or or pattern string sequence
that's right which one pattern string
sequenced sequence yeah patterned it
would be better
yeah okay we we're going to have to have
um consistent names there
between these options and such like
okay
what does that mean oh it's DNA by
default oh it's DNA if it can be it's
RNA if it has a u in it that's
right that is an obscure message please
write that so people can actually
understand it compatible types hello
we're in you know we're a abstract type
inference system which is not what we're
talking about here yeah right just say
just say it's neither DNA nor an
LNA yeah is is not is not recognized as
DNA RNA or peptide you got
it
why is I thought this totally random
thing but I didn't know that bracka one
had a I mean I would have expected it
would just say Gene bracka
one not Gene bracka one comma some other
weird
thing are there multiple versions of
blacka one
somehow why does this when it says Gene
why isn't it just saying bracka
one yeah it is
is using the gene standard name there it
maybe we could I'll make it use the gene
symbol
instead well I don't know I'm just
asking this question I mean you're not
I'm not I'm not necessarily complaining
I'm just saying if that is the gene it
is just bracka one it is not this thing
with an annotation
right that's
right but what is this thing with The
annotation it's a some kind of Gene
extended name or something that's
right okay I just should be understood
what that should actually be I'm not
sure why don't we just saying bio
sequence here I mean everything's
reference
that makes
sense
okay now what does this
mean yes uh this means that they're uh
they're concatenated together how can
you concatenate a protein in a piece of
RNA yeah it's it's it's pretty
fascinating the uh it's something it is
physically possible this was what
Emerald especially asked for okay fine
all right okay
okay not go into the details what
exactly is the
clue yes and also is it is it always a a
string or can you make like a you know a
picture of a dinosaur or something out
of I mean you can right you can make a
network a non-rival one yes so how do we
represent that
later okay but have we thought about so
so this is this is like an edge that's
right in the network and um later on
there might be attachment points just
like there are for molecules and just
like there would be for networks right
but I don't know how we would represent
that I mean we'd have each each
individual piece
um uh it is the factu to
network and each Edge has a type and the
the is are
nonrival chemicals that connect the
stuff
right is that really the right name
type course sequence type well sequence
type I think sequence type be better
than just
type I think I would use sequence type
it fits better with the next two M right
okay wow that's
wild these compound sequences may not be
happy creatures in the future because I
think they're going to be as you know
the general Network case what is it
going to do here you know if you have a
bio Network here bio sequence Network
for example or bio bi sequence graph
much like we have net graph in for
neuron Nets be a bio sequence graph and
then you subv value that with type what
are you going to get out you're going to
get
out you know you're going to get out a I
guess you're going to get out a graph
that has it'll be very weird I you you
you preserve the structure and just
replace the
edges yeah okay fair
enough it's
amusing
okay
it's kind of like like we have metric
graphs would be categorical
graph have what graphs what oh I see I
see I see
right now it gets a little bit
Advanced okay extended bio sequence
type so this is the way that you can
introduce your own
right that's neat I mean that's in
general something where we don't have
quite a uniform framework within the
language like that allows the same
extension for a new numeric integration
rule whatever right because guess what
the these things their tentacles are
very different
exactly right but so this is great that
we can do
this
um so these are ones that we already
have defined predefined ones is that
right or they're defined by virtue of
entity registering them right here yes
oh I
see oh I didn't notice that you had
three there okay oh wow so do not need
to say very much then but if I do this
but then I want to say biosequence
translate for example how does it know
how to translate a hatch Emoji DNA into
anything else
yeah it it uh it doesn't know that by by
default no but you can tell it
yes right now we can tell it how to
complement uh using these compliment
letter rules uh we could also Define a a
translation there was a previous
proposal for that but it was rather
rather
awkward has more letters than
m
I'm
sorryim has more letters I know I know I
know I know I know but so what I mean
that that's so so you've got in the
translation you've got to be able to say
I mean I have no idea what it actually
does maybe it makes a different set of
proteins as
well does
it I don't remember the papers who did
that okay I don't think they had gotten
quite there yet okay okay I think they
got it stable I think that's where they
are okay all right
okay but definitely the translation
could be folded into this entity store
yeah okay this looks pretty nice guys
okay let's keep going bio sequence Q I
understand what that
is bio sequence match
Q now I don't understand this because
we're going to need everything we're
going to need string position we're
going to need the whole ball of wax
right I want to know where this is on
that bio sequence I want to know uh you
know I want to know not just match CU
but I want to know given this thing
where there's a flanking sequence I mean
look the typical thing would be I've got
my bio sequence here that is my random
piece of DNA and I assume that faster
files will now import by default as bio
sequences yes no not yet okay but
there's at least going to be a bios
sequenced element for faster yes
absolutely I mean that that should be
trivial right okay but then then what I
would typically want to do is take a bio
sequence give flanking I mean what I
would say is string replace basically of
a bio sequence flanking sequence blah
blah blah x blank flanking sequence blah
blah blah Arrow X in other words I want
to know what what is in the actual bio
sequence in between those flanking
sequences that Mak sense yeah that's
reasonable yeah
um but right now we would have to
have all of these operations string
positions string cases string RPL all
these things would have to be
supported a bio sequence analog of those
things would have to be supported
correct I mean this is probably
something we want to avoid this probably
a little bit Overkill exactly so I think
one way to avoid it is to study the
possibility that we overload the string
functions
okay and take a look at what that would
involve because I I think that is
probably the best
idea and that it is a bio sequence to
bio sequence story with the string
functions and that we basically just say
string position because what we're doing
is referring to things in terms of the
strings I mean it makes sense because
what we're effectively doing is
extracting the sequence string from the
bio sequence doing the string operation
and stuffing the sequence string back
into the bio
sequence at least in most cases I mean
we wouldn't do that with string position
for example which you definitely want
here but it's slightly more complicated
because we take this degenerate on into
account it's not the literal string
operation that we carry out fair
enough fair
enough well I think that's that's fine I
mean I think that but then then I would
argue this thing should be a wrapper
okay because you should be able to say
this section I want nnn's in them but
this part here I want to be
strict you see what I'm
saying right so I think I strongly think
that we are you know unless we overload
string operations we're going to be in
deep dooo
here because let's look at how many
string operations there are the other
possibility would be to have one
function that takes as one argument the
corresponding string
function Al it's worried this will slow
down string functions don't worry it
will not whatever we do will not do that
no no no no I me I mean conceptually
like like Matrix function Matrix
function takes the function and Matrix
oh no I know I know I know I know I know
in this sense the problem is the
multi-argument forms are a mess
yes
I think we should I think we need all of
this stuff we need all this longest
sequence shortest sequence accept we
need all kinds of things
here I think we should try to I think we
should study the possibility of
overloading
these okay it might be aaable until all
of them can be
supported yeah well fair enough so some
of them but but look the the minimal way
you do it is you just extract the string
do the string operation go back but as I
just said it might not work because of
the different meaning of the letters I
understand that I understand that in the
case where you know give an error if you
see one that has non literals in it but
otherwise just exactly we're going to
need all this stuff all of it string
starts Q all this stuff we're going to
need all of that we should just not try
and re rebuild
it
um
yeah that's an interesting operation as
well that's again very interesting to do
with bio
sequences these are all good things and
and they should they should all work
rather easily because they all going to
work in the same way it'll be an up
value on bio sequence
that just looks at you know so no
slowdown of string
operations yeah we need all of these
string pad left we're going to need that
too I mean all kinds of
stuff all right this one you could
easily do with the compound
ones with which compound ones but a
sequence of sequences you could pet
yourself oh yes but in that particular
case all right I admit
and I admit that inserting line breaks
is an unconvincing operation in
DNA
um okay so this all becom string match
Q
um I think this is fine compliment and
reverse
compliment oh my God we got inverse
transcribed as
well oh this is getting a little
crazy do we really need inverse
transcribe I mean again there's some
convenience things here but then why
don't we throw them all into BIOS
sequence convert after that
when does that ever happen inverse
transcribe it's
um yeah fairly if people are doing this
single cell RNA seek analysis and
converting it back into their here even
though I say convert right there so uh
back into the DNA for matching it up
it's but it's it's a but okay well
whatever I I don't
know I I think we should throw a bunch
of things into biosequence convert and
these are merely convenience functions
which effectively call bio sequence
convert um now you're telling me that
translate okay what happens if the
codons don't line
up it uh for throws away the additional
terms and gives a
message and how does it work with start
codeon stop codons all those kinds of
good
things there's a
u in in the the future functionality
there's a a bio sequence modify that
moves to Cuts everything up to the start
codeon and then you can apply translate
from
there
but I would have thought biosequence
translate should say where I mean it
should have some options saying just go
to the start code
on and then start translating from there
or something but I mean what happens if
there are multiple start
codons it should take the the
first and what about I I don't know my
biology well enough all these open
reading frame type things things and so
on and all the all the ways that you can
get
overlapping I mean is that that just you
have multiple start codons and you can
start different places or how does that
work we don't have we don't have Bob
here that's a shame he would it's it's
it's more typically a more complicated
story by then by the time it actually
gets to translation all of that kind of
inter splicing has happened it's h it's
happened between uh it happens kind of
during the initial transcription so by
the time it how how do we represent that
stuff
here I mean is that something that that
is there is there a single transcription
or are there multiple transcriptions
that should be
represented there's there's really uh a
single one that should be represented
and the rest should be handled through
string operations it's so biologically
specific okay except I mean if I mean uh
let me just point out you know our
Market is creatures on planet Earth we
have only one form of life on planet
Earth so
any any anything you say it's very
specific but you know we've got however
many organisms then we all work the same
so if there's a you know in other words
there's
nothing yeah yeah it's only as
complicated as many organisms as there
are that's right no no no no that's not
what I meant that's not what I meant if
there are generic mechanisms then we
should parameterize those they should
have names and we should say how to do
those kinds of transcriptions
right oh yeah that that's kind that's
the next the next phase is integrating
the uh the coding region work in genes
with with this this this functionality
so how is that what's it going to look
like
roughly I don't know yet okay does
anybody know because we don't want to
make sure we don't want to close this
design without understanding that to
some extent
do you understand what I'm saying I so
if I go look up you know what's a nice
short Gene anybody know a nice short
Gene
[Music]
um let's see I am picking a random genan
here okay here's a nice reasonably short
gen of cyto
Chrome
okay so let's understand what this is
saying it's really a shame that Bob is
not
here okay so this splicing structure
I mean both there a couple of things
here which we're seeing the splicing
structure and the snip
positions I'm also concerned about
coordinate systems here so if I've
extracted this bio sequence does it
carry around its coordinate
position
uh I think it should or I mean if you if
you if you say uh Gene entity you you'll
get back some meta information about
it no I understand that but what I'm
asking is if I look at this biosequence
and then I find this thing TT AAA
whatever I want to know where was that
because I I want to ultimately I want to
match that up with a snip for
example how am I going to do that yeah
there's a bio sequence locate uh for
work following
12.2
but what you think it's going to
do well
uh I I think it will uh you kind of give
it kind of the larger structure you're
looking in whether it's the genome or
particular chromosome or what kind of
what have you uh and then the the the
sequence is a second argument and your
returned uh some you know alignment
objects that tell you kind of where it
is how well it's aligned um and and this
sort of inform
information sorry you've got a
biosequence and you ask that relative to
the whole of the human gen gen genome
right right okay but there's a different
thing which is I've got a little
piece and I want to
know okay listen let's say I've got a
collection of whatever these were cypb
genes okay I done a big study
okay I've got a whole bunch of
those and a different or a bunch of
mitochondria for example okay and I'm
now asking questions
about I'm a little confused about this
how this works well okay but but so
let's start off with a splicing
structure right so this is a rather
simple
case but
um
okay
so this is an
intron if I'm not mistaken so this is
being broken into this is the splicing
structure
yep be nice we have more spaces around
those but anyway
okay okay so I'm a little confused by
this picture so that that's a piece of
DNA that we thrown away is that
right that's a piece that is going to be
transcribed then it is spliced together
with this piece here which is going to
be transcribed is that right that's
right it's kind of weird picture because
this should show dot dot Dots here or
something rather than this thing because
this effectively this region in the
middle is like this white region is
going to be thrown away
right
um although
um I guess there regulatory differences
between the two but in general
yeah by the way how do I find the
molecular weight so for for a given
biosequence can I can I use how would I
compute the moleular weight of that Pio
sequence the corresponding
protein maybe we need that as a sub
value yeah I mean right now you can get
molecules out for small ones and but
what about a big one I mean it's easy to
compute so why don't you just say um
protein molecular weight okay for any
biosequence where you know which can
know how it's transcribed now presumably
if it has ends in it and things and it's
a DNA quence there'll be a range of of
proton Mo protein molecular weights you
get an interval back
presumably
um but this may be a little bit over I
not
have just the molecular weight sub value
and then if you wanted the body in you
first convert
yourself it seems to me a little bit too
far away kind of asking for the
molecular we or the protein molecular
weight of a DNA sequence that's true
well the molecular weight of the DNA
sequence itself is probably not that
interesting to
anybody why not for
mpect don't know no don't know enough
about
it but I mean this is a typical thing
that one talks
about
good
um okay all right so this splice ability
business
so this is ultimately going to be called
something like bio sequence splicing or
something and it will be a wrapper
around the bio
sequence
um
right and then yeah so okay I I'm still
trying to understand this the
um the translat how it deals with stop
codons and all that kind of
stuff
uh I'm I'm a little confused and what
it's going to and I suspect that there
need to be more options to sequence
translate right to deal with um you know
what to do so for example if it sees a
start code on a stop code on that sees
another start code on a stop code on
does it return two different translated
bio sequences in a list or what does it
do right now it it will apply all the
way through so that you'll get
uh a single which is been spliced
together yeah with you and you'll see
through there'll be multiple periods in
there which is in the notation for stop
code on which can then be that's put
aart
on I'm not sure that's right and I mean
what you've got here is you're looking
at the diversity associated with the you
know wildc card letters here which
you're putting in a list but then
there's a different meaning to the list
which is the sequence of things seen
from different um splicing regions and
so
on different you know start stop regions
now by the time translation has actually
happened all the splicing operations
have taken place so may maybe the kind
of the right place understand that I
understand that but if if you give me a
sequence of DNA
here which has two start codons in it
right what is it going to
do and if it doesn't have a start code
on at all what does it
do so this is the what's here is kind of
the naive version where someone wants to
just wants to say what would this be if
it was translated as it was okay okay
okay fine so but how does it line up the
codons
so it's so yeah every three from the
beginning who knows well that's right
okay fine so that's another thing that's
another option is what the you know what
the phase is when it starts doing
that aren't there okay uh biology
question I I I don't know why we didn't
have Bob here or other people who know
about this but I mean you know when
there are proof eeding enzymes and
things isn't isn't there a certain
degree of proof reading that gets done
okay if there is a an EXT ra
character in the DNA
sequence or the RNA sequence what
happens during
transcription oh it yeah if it's
actually in the sequence it will get
uh translated
incorrectly no it won't not if it isn't
code not if it isn't a valid code
on
oh yeah the
uh so
the space of all all all three all com4
possible combinations and there are 20
amino acids I know yeah and they're all
it's degenerate so multiple codons map
to the same amino acid so the the entire
space is covered degenerately okay I was
just Stephen did you say so as far as I
know there isn't a form
codeon I see what you're saying you're
you're saying that all of those codons
me transcribe to something that's right
okay all right fine
um I I would like to do a review here
where we actually have some more people
who know about this molecular biology
this is kind of crazy because there's a
bunch of questions I have which which I
don't think we're going to know the
answer to here okay I try to find
somebody ask the emerald guys for
example they know this stuff yeah um and
uh I think our friend Trevor is probably
too busy
decoding uh that's why we didn't try
even to get him right now he's he's he's
he's absolutely in the um virus uh
genealogy
business
um although I still wonder what the
actual viral clock really
is which is a big
question
um okay the various comments on our live
stream here about from Vladimir
particularly asking about protein
folding which is a challenging business
I mean we we do have RNA structure
right is that no we don't have have that
but we were about to have that
right yeah Emerald has that yeah they
have we're giving us some feedback on
that intended for post 12.2 yeah okay
but so so the part that we are going to
be able to do fairly
straightforwardly is
um uh RNA structure which is vastly
easier than protein
structure what I mean we should ask our
friend Muhammad who has been who's now
winning all the protein structure
competitions we should ask him whether
there's something we could use from his
work okay do you know him yeah I we've
corresponded briefly he's a good guy
yeah right but he now is winning the
protein structure competitions so let's
he has something to um uh and he would
also be a person who would know this
stuff cold abely maybe we should see if
he can join us for another one of these
meetings
um but particularly I it will be
fantastic to get some of his modern uh
you know protein structure prediction
capabilities
um yeah Ali is pointing out we should
have somebody who is a bioinformatics
expert yes I mean this meeting it
doesn't make sense without more I mean
this is very much an expert meeting and
we don't have the right level of experts
here um not because we had a couple pre
meetings with them I thought we zoomed
in on a minimal set we would agree on
yes I understand but but you know me
Michael by now I'm going to end up
asking all these questions about how how
things work and it's not going to okay
bi sequence convert what's the
difference between convert oh that
that's the general convert function
that's right
right conversion count what is
conversion count is it string length of
the
result it's the number of potential
results if you call it
all well how can it be an
interval so if there's degenerate terms
or in the case of you know how there's
how codons map degenerate no no you're
no you're not answering my question if
it's a count if it's the number
of is count the possible
lengths
of the peptides or is count the number
of distinct forms that can be generated
the number of distinct forms that then
why is it an interval why isn't it just
a number BEC because without doing the
conversion you because of these
degenerates oh that's silly are you
saying you can't figure it out
combinatorially yeah you it on the
identity of what the re what are you
talking about no it doesn't look look
it's either a definite number that has
you know the N either stands for four
different
things right what what are you saying
you're saying you can't figure this out
out the
combinatorics because there's a definite
answer to what the number of distinct if
you were to do the conversion
right then you would get some number of
outputs correct
a definite number of outputs there's no
interval to the number of outputs you
get you get a definite number of outputs
true or not
true that's true you always end up with
the same number of outputs okay so
there's no like Quantum process going on
here where we might have an unnown
unknown number of outputs okay we have a
certain number of outputs this function
bio sequence conversion count counts the
number of outputs we are going to get is
that
correct that's right yeah so then what
the heck is it doing with an interval
is that because you can't figure out how
many outputs you're going to get that's
right because whether it's uh say a y or
an S both of those generate potentially
two you know two different U specific
chemicals but uh depending onc because
of the uh the codons are mapped into uh
different numbers uh into degenerately
unless you know wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait you can you can compute
this right so bio sequence conversion
count could be implemented as length a
bio sequence convert is that correct
that's true yeah okay so you're trying
to do an efficiency hack that's right to
estimate the number okay have you
thought about actually doing the common
toric to figure out how what what the
answer will be because I bet that's
possible I bet you just have to have
some you know finite state transmuter
that goes down the string accumulating
numbers and mult blinding things
together when it hits another you know
unknown I mean it's basically a count of
the number of pars there are through
that finite State machine is that true
or is that not
true that that sounds plausible I I you
know okay so that's a super fast thing
to figure out it's not as fast as
knowing just the length of the string
but it's super fast thing to figure out
yeah I I'll look into that yeah I think
I I can I I'm not 100% convinced I think
you will overc count with this method
why because there will be some that turn
out to be the same and you don't
identify this on the way I see what
you're saying right the path I see what
you're saying that okay so
Michael no no no no I think we can do it
I think if we can make let me think
about this if we can make a
deterministic final automaton rather
than non-deterministic
one I think if we can do the
minimization at the level of finite
State machine we should be able to to do
it I don't I don't know whether the
thing is a finite State machine I I I
remember looking at this many many years
ago for completely different reason
about how transcription works and um but
yeah in a slightly different context so
I'm not sure but any case I don't think
um
uh um
yeah okay I I don't understand the point
of this function I mean if if we have
this why don't we just say saying you
know given this no it's it's it's meant
for the case if this would return 10 to
the
32 yeah I understand I
understand but but why don't we just
have something which produces a message
if the number is ridiculously
large it just seems like a it seems like
a nobody's ever going to call this you
know you know they're just going to call
biosequence convert and then it's either
going to blow up their machine or it's
not um and I mean maybe we can have a
Max items option to bio sequence convert
which is by default set to some number
10,000 I don't know what number it
should be set to okay and if you really
want everything you set max items to
infinity and otherwise it will limits
the max items with a message see what
I'm saying yeah that makes a lot of
sense what that's a much more
straightforward
path okay all right
fine I mean being able to estimate this
would be nice but I think it seems like
a luxury
item okay resolve degenerate
letters why are you calling them
letters uh I guess because they're part
of uh terms in an
alphabet well that's just an
analogy
um I just say we're not entirely happy
with the name here there are some other
candidate names that we came up with
shown below that result but what
certainly we're open to a resolve to
generate I mean this is something that
we don't
have like if we have a regular
expression we don't have a function that
says partly because the number could be
infinite you know resolve me all the all
the like we could say give me
all the sequences consistent with this
regular expression up to some
length is this actually useful this
thing about resolving degenerate forms
like
this oh yeah um yeah it it it ends up uh
I guess mattering quite a bit to as to
what peptides you could you could
convert
to among other well I understand that
but but that's in BIOS sequence convert
you just convert right so why do you
need to
pre you know what this is a silly
function why don't we just have it be
part of biosequence convert okay it's
it's convert to itself it's convert from
DNA to DNA but resol in the because it's
going to do exactly the same thing it's
resolving the
degeneracies right but if I said here
just convert from DNA to DNA I would get
the exact same thing
correct right now it doesn't resolve
degeneracies but let's make it so that
it does and that wait wait wait wait
wait wait excuse me what do you mean it
doesn't resolve degeneracies what's this
no I mean if you convert if you said
convert DNA to
DNA
uh well it should it should what does it
right now uh it's it's a uh it's an
identity no I think I don't think it
should because it
would violate the principle
of of the shape of the
result well but it's doing it here look
at this case here but there's a third
argument oh well okay then it should do
you're right it should do it in the case
of the third argument that's how you
should get okay fine good
okay
yeah Ali is correctly pointing out that
the name for the function should be
resolved de generously if we had it but
we I don't think we need
it yes p is pointing out a codon on
nucleotides three nucleotides is one
codon yes then Mr a is like a little
machine indeed that's that's that's why
I'm yaking about finite State machines
and the ribosome acting like a finite
State
machine
um wild does that actually make any
sense doesn't the thing need end caps of
some
kind yeah oh it has you say No Cap DNA
right
right there's what is this I don't
understand this biosequence here what's
the second argument to molecule I never
saw a second argument to molecule what's
the second argument to molecule right no
uh so we haven't I haven't talked with
so we need to come up with a better um
what do you by the way here with a raft
disappearing somebody should report that
that must be a 122 bug uh Tom sh knows
amazing that goes wrong almost every
version okay in any case Okay so sorry
um Jason you were just saying um right
so that's not the syntax that we would
we would land on in the end um is to
right so so if by if you need options
for how to convert a biosequence to a
molecule then we would need then it
would need its own uh uh Constructor
function right I think it should be part
of Bio sequence
convert why not bio sequence convert to
molecule and then you can have you know
to you could say no cap DNA
molecule and then it happily returns a
molecule rather than a
biosequence
suggestion
yeah I mean the case where it's just a
straight conversion but but explain to
me about the
endcaps Somebody explain that or is
anybody not know nobody know here I I
just don't think that can possibly be
right I think this is just a purely
notional thing I don't think you can I
don't think that works that
way and isn't that the same you got to
have somebody in here who actually knows
this stuff I'm sorry this
is wrongly set up okay in any
case that is
wild that is a wild creature look at
that wild
creature it's entertaining I give it
that but why isn't that random sequence
DNA quotes
nnn I mean that could be a short hand
for nnn and N andn 50 times it actually
biosequence DNA come up 50 is a short
hand for nnn 50 times okay fine so I can
as well say here if I wanted to I could
say something like
this I could say n
NTS is that so I don't remember what the
S is one of those things oh kol asaurus
okay that's
nice it's a little funky it's like I
mean gradually random instan is going to
be used in more and more places but
right now it's it's old uclid and bio
sequences are there any others
I don't think so I think that's it
that's
it this comes to my
mind okay is this consistent with the
way that random Choice
Works yes I think
so find out because the raft is going
away
okay so what you're saying is there's a
similarity rules which we already had
didn't we for sequence
alignment yeah this Builds on the
existing similarity rules
option
um
is that the right term genetic
translation
table I believe so okay all
right that's cool all right
fine it really is amazing how everything
in this world is computational at some
level including as we now know physics
but the fact that this is so structured
is really amazing I'm just sorry this
just my little um it is quite
remarkable
um you know just think about all those
organisms that that lived and died
making sure that um uh you know that
some particular letter here was the
thing that won out in some struggle for
life back in the Precambrian or
something anyway never
mind
Frozen history or something um okay so
we make some changes based on your
remark make the convert much more
General think about think about the
string functions and then yes the string
function is probably the biggest thing
and let's let's do one with some actual
experts yeah and I'm not I mean more
experts um the thing function I said I
don't think we will be able to support
them all for 122 that might be I
understand but look just supp what do we
do if we need some more options that are
not
available talk to me about it okay I
would generally think we could just
provide let them work in the overloaded
forms of the string functions and
basically have anything in the pattern
rather than as an option to the string
function yes and that's strict
degenerous that that thing should be a
pattern rapper
yeah I mean look at some level it's a
hack to use letters but you know it's it
is the the standard hacker
bioinformatics and I don't think we
should you know it's silly it's just
like we
say
um I mean it's an interesting question
all right whether we should support in
naked strings a rapper that means this
is essentially a a
bio
I mean yeah that's effectively what
we're doing we can have the pattern be a
bio
sequence right both both the thing that
is being looked at and the pattern could
be I was wondering about this I I don't
I didn't like this scenario because like
for molecule we have molecule
pattern for
thingss it's slightly
different well think about it a bit okay
what I'm suggesting is you have a naked
string but you want to do matching bio
sequence like matching where n can match
any of whatever right it's like it's
like saying you know it's like the
annotations that we have for string
matching that allow different sort of uh
I don't know special like regular
expression is a good example where we're
taking a string of characters but
interpreting it as a regular expression
this is a similar kind of thing but then
you might also want to zoom one level
out then we need to rate them
supported
no we don't not for
Strings no I speak about bio
sequences we want to match a n against
the literal n and only literal n well
that's exactly what you've got with that
the resolve that that strict non
degenerate thing that's exactly what
that is and possibly we should just use
verbatim for
that see what I'm saying in in the
sequence matcher right here wherever it
was where you've
got this
function
this strict bio sequence pattern why not
just use
verbatim to say verbatim
n in the
pattern just like we would for a um you
know a regular string
pattern actually I don't think we need
to do that in a string pattern but we
would do that in a ordinary in a
expression
pattern we would use it for Star say in
the string yes quite I think you should
use verbatim for this it's very clear
what it
means all right um I think if this
covers all cases in both dire I'm not
sure yeah I'm not sure but if if if not
that it's some kind of thing like this
that is a rapper oh we have two more
questions on our live stream wonder how
to compute mutations I mean that's what
the whole sequence alignment stuff means
here
um again I'd like to
know yeah I assume we've looked at other
you know systems people use for
bioinformatics and for example the the I
mean I
know whenever I go looking at my genome
which I have to admit I do rarely
um you know the typical thing is I want
to find this particular
snip or I want to and I typically do it
by by just matching with flanking
sequences because I've given up you know
which build of the human genome is this
etc etc
etc
um yeah anyway okay
um okay uh we had a question from Ali is
there a meeting on computational
Geometry coming up I do not know I see a
meeting about synthetic geometry on
Thursday um that's not quite
computational geometry I don't oh um
good
question uh I know there will be before
122 because there's a bunch of
functionality there I don't know exactly
when it is all right well thanks to
everybody here and Michael and John I
look forward to seeing the next
iteration of this but it's looking good
looking good thank you okay and thanks
to folks on the live stream see youall
later